what expression can be used to show
dividing 18 boxes into two equal stacks
find the expression three times using
different ways to write division find
the value of the expression so let's
just little do this top part right here
we have 18 boxes and we divide want to
divide them into two equal stacks so we
want to divide 18 by two and the way we
would write this we'll think a little
bit more about what this means we could
write this as 18 over 2 this means 18
divided by 2 we could write it as 18 we
could write it as 18 divided by 2 just
like that or we could write it as 18 18
divided by divided by 2 now before we
evaluate it they say find the value of
the expression let's think about what
this means we have 18 boxes and we want
to divide them into two equal stacks let
me draw 18 boxes so I have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 almost there
13 14 15 16 17 18
so those are my 18 boxes and I divide
them into two equal stacks or two equal
groups
so if I want to make if I want to divide
these into two different groups that
have the same number of boxes I could
just eyeball it and say well let me put
one of let's make these top ones one
group let's make that one of the groups
and let's make these bottom ones let's
make these bottom ones another group and
these are equal groups how many do we
have in each group on the top one we
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine and in the bottom one we have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine so we were split it into two groups
of nine
so 18 divided into two equal groups is
equal to is equal to 9 or 18 divided by
2 is equal to 9 or 2 goes into 18 nine
times